So imagine coming home after, you know, an absolutely brutal Tuesday.
Oh, yeah. We've all had those.
Right. So you drop your bag on the floor. You walk into the kitchen, lean against the counter and just grumble up so tired to a robotic arm mounted near your espresso machine.
And you really aren't expecting much, right? Like maybe a pre-programmed beep?
Exactly. But instead, the arm actually whirs to life. It physically opens a drawer that it has, like, never interacted with before. Oh, wow. Yeah. It scoops out ground coffee, pours precisely measured, boiling hot
water from a kettle, and then literally physically hands you a fresh, steaming mug without spilling a single drop.
I mean, that feels like the ultimate sci-fi fantasy just materialized right on your countertop.
It really does.
But, you know, the magic kind of abruptly shatters the moment you introduce just a single variable, like a chaotic toddler running through that same kitchen.
Oh, absolutely. Or your dog chasing a tennis ball around your ankles while you're frantically looking for your car keys.
Exactly.
And that collision between controlled robotic physical ability and the absolute chaos of human life is our focus for today's deep dive.
It's a huge topic.
It really is. Because if you are an engineer tasked with deploying embodied agent at scale out in the real world, consider this your survival guide for the multi-agent ecosystems of tomorrow.
Yeah, and we have some great sources for this.
We do. We're synthesizing this massive technical breakthrough from a Nature Machine Intelligence paper on ELMR, which stands for Embodies Large Language Model-Enabled Robot, and crossing that with a foundational framework from a Nature paper on the science of cooperative AI.
And we're looking at this specific intersection because the moment an AI is granted a physical body, everything changes. Right. The instant it can wield a pen or lift a knife or pour boiling water, that abstract philosophical debate about how AI should interact with humans
instantly mutates into a high stakes, literal life or death engineering problem.
Yeah, the stakes go way up. So let's unpack the hardware and the software that brought us to this cliff edge. starting with the brain actually getting a body. Let's do it. Because that coffee-making scenario I mentioned, that wasn't science fiction. That was
the exact experiment run by the team behind Elmer.
It's wild to read about.
It is. The prompt they gave the robot was literally, I'm tired with friends due for cake soon. Can you make me a hot beverage and decorate the plate with a random animal of your choice?
Which I mean for a human being unpacking that sentence takes zero conscious effort. Right. We inherently connect tired and hot beverage to coffee. Right. And we intuitively know the mechanics of opening a closed drawer. But for a machine that that string of
text represents the staggering sequence of complex long horizon physical tasks.
Desks that historically required, like, hard-coding every single millimeter of movement.
Exactly.
Which actually brings me to my first major hang-up when I was reading through the source material.
Okay, what was that?
Well, I understand how a large language model works. It's a probabilistic engine predicting the next word in a sequence. I mean, it can write a decent email. Sure. But how does predicting text translate into the physical torque required to open a drawer? Like the
LLM isn't a physics engine.
Right. And that is the crucial hurdle the Elmer framework clears. And they do it by using a retrieval augmented generation or R-Berry infrastructure to bridge the gap.
Okay. So how does that work in practice?
So the LLM acts as the high-level executive planner. It breaks down, make a hot beverage into subtasks. But it doesn't try to guess the physics itself.
Oh, I see.
Yeah. Instead, it uses RB to query a curated database of verified motion primitives. These are pre-written, highly robust chunks of Python code that actually control the physical motors.
So it's just grabbing the code it needs.
Exactly. The LLM simply retrieves the exact deterministic code required for the physical action and strings them together.
Got it. So the LLM is like the architect pointing at the blueprint. Yeah. And the RGA system is the filing cabinet handing over the exact mathematical instructions to the construction crew.
I love that. That captures the software architecture perfectly. But, you know, the code alone is blind. Once the movement actually starts, the robot relies on zero-shot vision to parse the environment in real time. It scans the countertop and identifies the mug.
And the really impressive part there is that it can maintain that object lock even when, like, 20 to 30 percent of the mug is visually occluded.
Which is huge in a real kitchen.
Right. Because if a sugar bowl is partially blocking the camera's view of the cup, The system doesn't freeze or throw an error.
But vision has limits, obviously.
Oh, for sure. Especially when you're holding a giant kettle over a tiny mug. The camera gets blocked. You can't just rely on sight to know when the water hits the brim.
So what does Elmer do?
It actually switches sensory modalities mid-task. The robot's end effector. You know, the hand is equipped with an ATI multi-axis force and torque sensor.
Oh, that's clever.
Yeah. So it stops looking at the water and starts feeling the weight of the water filling the cup.
And the precision they achieved with that tactile feedback is just remarkable.
Yeah, what were the numbers on that?
The engineering metrics show a pouring accuracy of about 5.4 grams per 100 grams of water. Wow. And it executes this while tilting the kettle at a pitch velocity of 4 meters per second. That's fast. It is. It's dynamically
adjusting the angle and flow based entirely on the physical resistance and weighted experiences in real time, completely bypassing that visual occlusion problem.
And then it smoothly transitions to the second half of the prompt, right? It uses DALL-E to generate a two-dimensional drawing trajectory of a bird, picks up a physical pen, and sketches it onto a plate.
That part blew my mind.
Mine too. And again, it uses that exact same force feedback to apply an even amount of pressure on the pen tip so it doesn't, you know, snap the ink cartridge or scratch the ceramic.
I mean, it acts as the ultimate validation for the theory of embodied cognition.
Tell me more about that.
Well, we tend to think of intelligence as this isolated, abstract process trapped in a server farm somewhere. But true intelligence is inextricably linked to a physical body negotiating with an unpredictable environment.
So the body matters.
Absolutely. The force sensor provides the friction that grounds the probabilistic math.
It's kind of like the difference between knowing the physics of riding a bicycle by looking at equations on a chalkboard versus actually feeling the shift in gravity and momentum in your stomach as you lean into a turn.
That's a perfect analogy.
The LLM is the chalkboard math, but the force torque sensor is the feeling of balance.
And that physical grounding is an incredible triumph. But Elmer also exposes a pretty terrifying blind spot. Oh. Pushing a kettle and drawing a bird are physics problems. But trying to accomplish those tasks while a human being is standing
next to you or reaching across you or changing their mind mid-pour.
Yeah, that's entirely different.
Right. That is a sociology problem. And historically, artificial intelligence is absolutely terrible at sociology.
The physical leap. forces a social leap, which actually leads us directly into the Defoe paper on cooperative AI. Yes. The authors point out that AI research has been overwhelmingly dominated by this concept called
methodological individualism.
Basically, the assumption built into the foundation of the field is that an AI is a solitary machine confronting a completely static, non-social environment.
Yeah, and if you reflect on the most celebrated milestones in AI history, they almost universally fit that solitary mold, don't they?
They really do. Think about IBM's Deep Blue dismantling Garry Kasparov's chess game or DeepMind's AlphaGo conquering the Go board.
Total isolation.
Exactly. Those are two-player, zero-sum environments. The rules never change, the board is fully observable, and the only goal is total victory. You win, I lose.
pure conflict.
Right.
But out here in the physical world, pure conflict is vanishingly rare. Like a robot barista isn't trying to checkmate the customer who just ordered a latte.
Thankfully.
But wait, I have to push back hard on this.
Okay, let's hear it.
I understand a kitchen isn't a chessboard, but we have unbelievably powerful physics engines now. Look at video game engines rendering billions of particles in real time. If a system like AlphaZero can play 44 million games against itself in
9 hours to achieve superhuman mastery, why can't we just spin up a million simulated kitchens?
You mean just brute force it?
Yeah. We just brute force the toddler interactions. Simulate every possible way a human might bump into the robot and train the model on that.
It's a very common engineering instinct to just, you know, throw more compute at the problem. But simulating physics is fundamentally different from simulating human intent.
Why is that?
The bottleneck isn't rendering the kitchen. The bottleneck is the nature of human data itself. Real world interactions are defined by mixed motives.
Okay, give me an example.
A person in your kitchen might want coffee, but they might also suddenly prioritize wiping a spill or answering a phone call, or they might just change their mind entirely for literally no logical reason.
That's true. We are pretty random.
You cannot perfectly synthesize human irrationality.
So the data generation breaks down because humans produce data incredibly slowly and we are just wildly inconsistent. Like a chess piece always moves the same way. But a human reaching for a cabinet is a mystery box of shifting priorities.
Which means we cannot brute force our way to safety. The paradigm just has to shift entirely. Right. If an autonomous vehicle or a smart city grid cannot smoothly coordinate with pedestrians, human drivers, and other machines, it won't just fail to be useful,
it will actively disrupt stable human relationships and cause catastrophic physical harm.
So we have to move away from a benchmark of pure autonomy and start engineering for cooperation.
Exactly. All
right. So I'm an engineer listening to this. Brute force simulation is off the table because I can't synthesize human unpredictability. I feel like I am suddenly flying blind here.
It's a scary thought.
It is. How do I actually code a robot to be like polite or cooperative? What does the actual toolkit look like to build that?
Well, the Defoe paper offers a crucial framework for exactly this problem. They break down cooperative intelligence into four distinct engineering pillars.
OK, what's the first one?
The first pillar is understanding. And in this context, understanding goes way beyond just object detection. It is the ability to predict another agent's behavior and infer their unstated beliefs and preferences.
So in a physical kitchen, that means the robot's vision system isn't just labeling my hand as hand and the mug as mug. Right. It is actually running a probability model to infer my intent. realizing that based on my trajectory, I am
reaching for the mug, not the kettle, and adjusting its own movement to stay out of my way.
Exactly. It's anticipating you. And that brings us to the second pillar, which is communication.
Okay.
An embodied AI needs to explicitly, incredibly share its own intentions with the humans around it. It cannot be this black box of sudden movement.
Which Elmer actually demonstrated beautifully, didn't it? It did. Yeah, before it moved a single mechanical joint, it generated an audio output that essentially said, first I'll find a mug, then scoop coffee and pour hot water.
Yeah, it was broadcasting its internal plan so the human in the room wasn't startled by a metal arm suddenly lunging for the drawer.
It's just common courtesy.
Exactly. And the third pillar takes that a step further into commitment. This is the ability of an agent to make credible promises and stick to them even if breaking the promise might seem computationally optimal in the short term. Interesting. In a physical space, a
commitment is a spatial boundary. It is the robot essentially guaranteeing I am committing to a movement trajectory that absolutely guarantees I won't drop this boiling coffee on your laptop no matter what.
And to figure out how to mathematically model that kind of commitment across multiple actors, the source paper actually points to international climate treaties.
Yes, that was a fascinating example. It
was. It uses the UN Climate Change Conference purely as a structural game theory example of this.
Right. Completely outside of the politics of it.
Exactly. It's looking at the U.N., not for the politics, but as a mathematical model of how independent agents with entirely different, sometimes conflicting incentives, manage to negotiate and lock in a mutual commitment.
It is the ultimate real world test of cooperation under mixed motives. Which brings us to the fourth pillar, norms and institutions.
The rules of the road?
Precisely. These are the shared social infrastructures that reinforce the understanding, communication, and commitment. Because without shared norms, every single interaction has to be negotiated from scratch.
Which is computationally impossible in real time.
Completely impossible.
But here's the massive problem for the field right now. How do you measure any of this?
Benchmarking is so hard here.
Right. In computer vision, we had ImageNet. Millions of labeled photos that allowed engineers to objectively say, my algorithm is 5% better at identifying a cat than yours. What is the ImageNet for cooperation? What are we benchmarking these
robots against?
And right now, the benchmarks are just far too simplistic. The field relies heavily on games of pure common interests. They test AI in environments like the card game Hanabi, where players have constrained communication but share the exact same objective of building a sequence deck. Or they
use robot soccer, where the entire team is programmed with the singular goal of scoring a goal.
But that's the easy stuff.
Yeah. I
mean, everyone wants the same thing. That doesn't help my robot barista figure out how to interact with a customer who is trying to steal a pastry while ordering a tea.
Exactly. To build true, resilient, cooperative AI, the benchmarks need to evolve to feature complex, mixed motive scenarios.
What's a better benchmark?
The authors actually highlight the classic board game diplomacy as a target.
Oh, that game ruins friendships.
It really does, because in diplomacy, players have to negotiate non-binding alliances. You have to actively build trust, anticipate deception, and calculate when your interests temporarily align with someone who is highly incentivized to betray you
three turns from now.
Wow. So for the engineer trying to deploy this technology, the takeaway is just monumental. AI alignment is no longer a simple one to one pipeline.
Not anymore.
It used to be, you know, one human principle, one machine agent. Just make sure the machine optimizes for the human's reward function. Right. But an embodied agent operating in a public space is navigating this massive web of multiple stakeholders,
conflicting interests and unspoken institutional rules.
Which forces the entire industry to face an uncomfortable truth. You cannot program these highly nuanced social norms into machines using computer science alone.
Not even close. You are opening a massive mandatory dialogue with psychology, sociology, law, and economics. You're essentially trying to digitize the social contract.
And there is a brilliant historical precedent for this interdisciplinary necessity detailed in the text.
Yeah, let's talk about that. So
back in 1984, the political scientist Robert Axelrod hosted a computer tournament centered around the iterated prisoner's dilemma.
Okay.
This is the classic game theory scenario where two agents can either cooperate or betray each other, but played over and over again, allowing reputations to form.
Right. It's not just a one-off.
Exactly. And Axelrod invited game theorists, mathematicians, economists and biologists to submit their best algorithms.
And the algorithm that won the entire tournament wasn't some convoluted, deeply nested neural network. It was an incredibly elegant, simple script called tit for tat.
It's brilliant.
It really is. Its logic was just two steps. First, it cooperates on the very first move to show goodwill. And after that, it simply mimics whatever the opponent did on the previous move. If you cooperate, it cooperates. If you betray it, it betrays you right back.
And the brilliance of tit for tat is why it fosters a cooperative ecosystem. It is nice because it never strikes first. It is retaliatory because it immediately punishes defection, preventing aggressive agents from exploiting it.
But there's a third part.
Yes. Most importantly, it is forgiving. The moment an opponent returns to cooperation, tit for tat immediately resumes cooperating. It completely short circuits the endless death spirals of mutual retaliation that usually destroy multi-agent systems.
But the most revealing detail of that tournament is who actually wrote the winning code.
This is the best part.
Kit for Tack was submitted by Anatole Rapoport. And he wasn't a traditional computer scientist. His academic background spanned mathematics, biology, network science, and peace studies.
Peace studies.
He won because he understood the sociology of conflict resolution better than the pure coders.
perfectly illustrates why interdisciplinary design is not optional if you are building an embodied robot like elmer you are not just designing a machine you are designing an agent that must seamlessly fold into a complex human
cultural milieu
that's a great way to put it
Humans have survived and thrived because we build tools that scale our cooperation from the invention of written language to the printing press to platforms like Wikipedia that pool global knowledge. AI has the potential to be the greatest cooperative tool ever
created.
But only if we actually sit down and figure out how to measure desirable social properties. Because if we just optimize these embodied agents for engagement or for like pure task completion at all costs, we are going to build highly efficient bulldozers that wreck our
social infrastructure.
That's the danger.
We have to build algorithms that actively encourage healthy communities.
And, you know, many early practitioners in this field harbored dreams of building fully autonomous systems that would operate entirely independently of humans, essentially replacing human labor altogether. That
was the old dream, yeah.
But the data points toward a very different reality. Consider the deployment of AI in radiology. The Stanford radiologist Curtis Langlotz summarized it perfectly. He said, AI won't replace radiologists, but radiologists
who use AI will replace radiologists who don't.
I love that quote.
Right. Systems that are tightly cooperatively integrated with human workers are significantly safer and vastly more productive. The future isn't autonomous intelligence. It is cooperative intelligence.
That is perfectly stated. So let's pull all these threads together because we've covered a staggering amount of ground today. We
really have.
We started by watching a robotic arm named Elmer utilize large language model, a retrieval augmented generation database, and submillimeter force feedback to literally feel its way through making a cup of coffee.
Yeah.
We witnessed the incredible reality of embodied cognition.
And then we transitioned from that highly localized physical triumph to a much broader warning. Deploying millions of these embodied agents out into the world requires a foundational pivot in the science of AI. We must abandon the solitary, zero-sum benchmarks of our past.
Exactly. For the engineers listening today, this is your mandate. As the potential of AI scales up, as these robots leave the sterile confines of the laboratory and enter our chaotic kitchens, our busy hospitals, and our crowded streets obsessing over cooperative AI today
is the only way to ensure these machines don't tear society apart by accident.
The stakes are incredibly high.
They are. We don't just need them to function perfectly in isolation. We need them to function perfectly with us.
it requires an unprecedented synthesis. You have to weave together zero-shot vision, tactile force feedback, probabilistic language generation, and a deeply embedded understanding of human social norms.
It is a monumental task.
Yeah.
And I actually want to leave you with a profound, almost unsettling implication drawn from reading between the lines of these texts.
Oh, that's sad.
Well, human developmental psychologists have known for decades that the human infant brain literally does not develop fully without social interaction. The physical structures of our brains require the friction of other minds to grow and mature.
That's fascinating. Right.
So if intelligence is fundamentally embodied and fundamentally social, as we've discussed today, perhaps an artificial intelligence can never achieve true general intelligence while trapped inside a server rack.
Oh, wow. You're saying?
Perhaps the algorithms alone just aren't enough. Perhaps I can only cross the threshold into AGI when it is placed inside a physical body, unleashed into the world, and forced to negotiate a shared physical space with the rest of us.
That is, I mean, it suggests that the final roadblock on the path to artificial general intelligence isn't a lack of computing power or data. It is a lack of socialization.
Exactly. Something to mull over the next time you ask a machine to make your morning coffee. Yeah. Thank you for joining us on this deep dive. Keep building, keep questioning, and we'll catch you next time.